فاجتماع عقد في العاصمه المؤقته عددا وقف
امام عدد من التطورات الراهنه على
المستويين المحلي والخارجي في ضوء التصعيد
المستمر وخيارات التعامل معها اصدر مجلس
الوزراء اليمني بيانا عن الاجتماع قال فيه
ان الركون على امكانيه رضوخ ميليشيات
الحوت للسلام
رهان خادع وكل تجارب تثبت ذلك وكذا ان
الطريق الوحيد للحل هو استكمال استعاده
الدوله مجلس الوزراء اليمني ناقش خيارات
الدوله والحكومه للتعامل مع التصاعد
العسكري للمليشيات خصوصا في حريب ومرق
وغيرها من الجبهات واستمرار اعمالها
الاجراميه واعتداءاتها المتكرره على
الاعيان المدنيه واستهداف المدنيين المجلس
اكد ان تصاعد الجرائم الارهابيه لميليشيات
الحوثي في ظل تحركات الاقليميه والاماميه
والدوليه للوصول الى حل سياسي لن تمر دون
عقاب او محاسبه مهما كلف ذلك من ثمن في
الجهه المقابله قال وزير الخارجيه
الايراني حسين امير عبد اللهيان خلال
معتبرا صحفي مع نظيره الروسيه في موسكو ان
طهران ترحب باي مبادره لانهاء الحرب في
اليمن كما اكد على اجراء محادثات هاتفيه
مع وزير الخارجيه السعودي لاجراء لقاء
مشترك وفي اقرب وقت
نرحب بالمحادثات الجاريه بشان اليمن ونرحب
باي مبادره لانهاء الحرب هناك واجريت
محادثات هاتفيه مع وزير الخارجيه السعودي
اكدنا فيها على العلاقات الثنائيه ونقشنا
اجراء لقاءات على المستوى الوزاري وافتتاح
السفارات ولتطوير تلك العلاقات يجب اتخاذ
الخطوات ونحن مستعدون لذلك
اشارك هنا الحوار حول هذا الملف من عدن
العقيده الركن ياسر صالح المحلى العسكري
والاستراتيجي وايضا من لندن بدر القحطاني
محرر الملف اليمني في جريده الشرق الاوسط
على ان ينضم الينا في بانوراما لاحقا نبدا
معك عقيد ياسر هل لم يحصل الحوثيون حتى
الان على ابديت فيما يتعلق بان المنطقه
تتجه الى المزيد من الانفتاح والمزيد من
السلام حتى يصعدوا عسكريا وميدانيا في
اليمن
نعم حقيقه الحوثيه هي تدرك جيدا المتغيرات
التي تحدث هي اصلا منذ نشاتها هي عباره عن
اداه لكل هذه المتغيرات سواء الدوليه او
الاقليميه وبالتالي تم اشعارها حتى مسبقا
بمعنى على سبيل المثال قبل توقيع الاتفاق
كان كبير المستشارين لوزاره الخارجيه
الايرانيه مجتمع معهم في طهران بعد جوله
مفاوضات ما بين المليشيا الحوثيه والجانب
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وايضا بعدها
زارهم نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي ولكن في
في طبيعه الحال نحن امام
منهجيه
تستخدمها
يستخدمها نظام الملالي
ومنه ايضا لاذرعه وهي استراتيجيه حافه
الهاويه عندما يتعلق الامر بالسلام او
بالمفاوضات
وتنتهج ايضا خذني حيث تريد ما دمت انتهي
بك حيث اريد كل الاطر على المستوى الدولي
لم لم الرؤيه نهائيا على المستوى الاقليمي
التجارب الكبير الذي حدث ولكن ايران لا
تريد ان تجازف كثيرا بان تضع
اذرعها كلما في يدها وبالتالي قبل ان
يتحقق المكاسب الكثيره وهذه ايضا
استراتيجيه واضحه دائما مع ايران على
المستوى المحلي المليشيا الحوثيه تعاني من
ضغط كبير على المستوى المحلي تحاول ان
تثبت بانها ليست رهينه للاداه كاداء
ايرانيه في المقام الاول
وهذا جاء عبر الرد من كثير من قياداتهم
بان الاتفاق لا يعنيهم وبالتالي تمارس
التوجيه تجاه الشعب اليمني اضافه الى ذلك
المشكله الاكبر في ذلك ان الميليشيا
الحوثيه
تعتمد على قدسيه الحكم الالهي واحقيتها
بالحكم وبالتالي في ظل النظام الجمهوري
الموجود في اليمن من الصعب الاستمرار او
تسلم السلطه نهائيا
بموجب اتفاقيه السلام وبالتالي لا يمكن ان
يؤول اليها هذا الحق سوى عبر اله الحرب
اهلا بك بدر
الى اي مدى يحاول الحوثيون
الاشاره الى انهم مستقلون في اتخاذ القرار
قرار الحرب والسلام في اليمن في ظل
التقارب الاخير ما بين المملكه وايران
مساء الخير عليك وعلى ضيوفك الكرام
والساده المشاهدين اعتقد عزيزي محمد لا
يوجد هناك فصل بين الحوثيين وايران لكن
اقرا وكثير من المراقبين الذين نتحدث معهم
يبدو ان هناك محاوله لاثبات هذه السرديه
بطريقه ستؤول في النهايه الى ان ايران هي
التي تتحكم بالقرار الحوثي المساله هي
مجرد مساله وقت اعتقد ان الحوثيين هناك
وساطه كما نعرف سعوديه بمشاركه عمانيه
واحاديث مع الحوثيين اعتقد ان الحوثيين
ينتظرون الردود من المملكه بخصوص بعض
المقترحات وهذا
التصعيد الذي نراه في الميدان هو عباره عن
رساله حوثيه بضروره استعجال ذلك وفي الوقت
نفسه كما تفضلتم محاوله للقول انه حتى لو
كانت الاجواء السياسيه بين السعوديه
وايران ايجابيه فنحن لسنا ايران وهذه وهذه
رساله للاسف الشديد تعطي
التذبذبا سواء لدى الجانب الايراني او من
ناحيه الحوثيين مع المجتمع الدولي المجتمع
الدولي كله يعرف ان ايران والحوثيين
مرتبطون ارتباطا عضويا لا يمكن للحوثيين
ان يكونوا جماعه وادبياتهم السياسيه وكل
الوعود التي يعيدون انصارهم بها كل
الاحاديث التي قالوها بعدما استولوا على
سلطه بالقوه كلها تتطابق اصلا مع التوجه
السياسي الايراني فبالتالي لا يمكن فصل
الحوثين عن ايران واعتقد ان 30 مليون يمني
يستحقون ان تنتهي هذه الازمه التي بدات
بكابوس الانقلاب في 2014 وما زالت تجتم
على
احلامهم ومستقبلهم بسبب بعض المكاسب
السياسيه التي ترجوها الميليشيات طيب عقيد
ياسر الحكومه اليمنيه كانت واضحه وهذا من
خلال تجارب مختلفه فيما يتعلق بالهدى
والسلام مع الحوثيين ولكن اذا كانت
المنطقه تتجه نحو السلام نحو المزيد من
الهدن من الهدن من اجل استقرار اقليمي
واسع ينطلق ربما من اليمن بشكل كبير هل لا
زالت الحكومه اليمنيه وقرائك مؤمنه بسلام
الحكومه اليمنيه هي مؤمنه بالسلام منذ اول
اللحظات سواء منذ
ذهبت الى المليشيا الحوثيه في عام 2013
ب 2012 مع المبعوثه الاممي الى اليمن
لمحاوله ادخاله في مؤتمر الحوار ثم
اتفاقيه الدخول معه في مؤتمر الحوار ثم
عدد من الزيارات التي
فشلت ثم بعد ذلك اتفاق السلم والشراكه الى
ان جاءت عاصفه الحزم وما بعدها اضافه الى
ذلك ان لدينا تجارب سته حروب كانت تنتهي
دائما بوساطه اما بريطانيه واما قطريه
واما محليه ودائما الميليشيا الحوثيه ما
تنتفض او تنقض هذه العهود والمواثيل
والمليشيا الحوثيه الحكومه ترى الميليشيا
الحوثيه من هذا المنظور وهي تدرك جيدا بان
مهما كانت الضغوط التي سترضخ لها
الميليشيا الحوثيه سواء في اتجاه المجتمع
الدولي او المجتمع الاقليمي وعلى راس
ايران
الرضوق الى انهاء الحرب في اليمن ووضع
حلول للسلام الا انها تدرك بان المليشيا
الحوثيه قبيل اي استحقاقات سياسيه ستنتفض
على كل هذه الاتفاقيه وستحاول ان تعيد فرض
سيطرتها عبر القوه وبالتالي هي يجب ان
تفكر بذلك مليا وعليها ان تجهز العده لان
لا يحدث انقضاض على الدوله مثل ما حدث
عليها انقضاب سواء بعد حكومه الوحده
الوطنيه او بعد اتفاقيه السلم وشراكه وهذا
شيء طبيعي او حراك طبيعي للحكومه رغم
ايقونتها وتاكدها بان الميليشيا الحوثيه
لا تسعى للسلام دائما كما تحدثت الميليشيا
الحوثيه ستموت بالسلام وباي استحقاقات
سياسيه
انتخابيه ديمقراطيه تفضل بدر القحطاني كان
هناك مبادرات خلال سنوات من الحرب في
اليمن كلها الى الان لم تصل الى النتيجه
المنشوده وهي تحقيق السلام والاستقرار في
اليمن هل هناك مبا دره قائمه الان قد يتم
البناء عليها من اجل سلام سريع في اليمن
اعتقد ان التحالف بقياده السعوديه فتح
ابواب عديده لانهاء الازمه اليمنيه ولو
لاحظنا منذ العام
2018 لم يعلن التحالف ولا الحكومه اليمنيه
اي عن اي عمليات هجوميه داخل اليمن وهذا
اذا اعطانا مؤشر فهو يعطي مؤشرا بان
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه كانت دافعه للسلام
عن طريق الضغط العسكري وهيستراتيجيه
دفاعيه
وبدات خفض التصعيد منذ العام 2018 الان
عندما وجدنا السعوديه فتحت باب الحوار مع
ايراني وفتحت باب في البدايه كان كان
خلفيا الان اصبحت تتوسط بمشاركه عمانيه مع
الحوثيين هناك ايضا لا ننسى الدعم الزخم
الدولي الذي كان يقوم به المبعوث الاميركي
تمبلندر كنج خلال العام 2021
المبعوث الاممي وكل المبعوثين الامويين
منذ دلاع الازمه لم يجدوا من التحالف
بقياده ودول التحالف الا كل الدعم كل هذه
الجهود كانت تذهب وتصب الى حل الازمه
اليمنيه مساله المبادرات ومساله الحلول
كلها مطروحه على الطاوله مشكله اليمن
تتمثل في ان هناك عصابه ليس لديك اي
التزامات دوليه وليس لديها اي تكلفه
سياسيه في ان تعرقل اي عمليه سياسيه لانها
بكل بساطه كانت في الاول تريد ان تحافظ
على المكتسبات الماليه والرواتب التي
تنهبها والاتاوات التي تفرضها عبر الموانع
وعبر مؤسسات الدوله التي سيطرت عليها
بالانقلاب والقوه الامر الاخر كان
الحوثيون يعتقدون انهم سوف ينجحون عسكريا
بالدعم الايراني لكنهم منذ العام 2021
تيقنوا تماما ان الانتصار العسكري مستحيل
وبالتالي بداوا يفاوضون ويتجاوبون مع
الامم المتحده ومع المبادرات التي تم
طرحها مشكله الازمه اليمنيه ان الحل معروف
الحل نعرف جميعا كيف سينتهي المشكله هي في
متى لان الحوثيين يريدون الاستفاده واطاله
امد هذه الازمه بحكم انهم يعتقدون انهم
يستنزفون الدول الاقليميه ويستهزفون
العالم عن طريق تهديده وتهديد ممراته
والاستيلاء على مقدرات شعب اليمني لكن
الدول المحيطه باليمن لا ننسى انها دول
غنيه وتستطيع
واثبتت انها تستطيع ان تحمل نفسها من يدفع
ضريبه الظلم الحوثي هو 30 مليون نسمه في
اليمن لم يجدوا خيرا منذ الكابوس الذي جثم
عليهم في عام 2014 وحتى اليوم بطل
القحطاني محرر في اليمني في جريده الشرق
الاوسط شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا ايضا للعقيده
روكن ياسر صالح المحلل العسكري والاستراتي